have you heard of the Wagner group it's
a private military company that has
suddenly gone from being a clandestine
mercenary group to a semi-official
extension of the Russian military most
recently the Wagner group is said to be
leading the fight against Ukrainian
forces for control of the Eastern town
of bakmut Russian forces have lost a lot
of ground in Ukraine so taking control
of Bak mood would be a symbolic victory
for Russian President Vladimir Putin and
it could all be thanks to these guys
Wagner mercenaries so let's talk about
where the Wagner group came from and
what role it's playing in the war in
Ukraine in September Russian oligarch
evgeny per goes and publicly
acknowledged that he was the founder of
the Wagner group before that he had been
known by the nickname Putin's Chef for a
successful restaurant business that
catered Kremlin dinners and had
contracts to provide meals to the
military he had denied any ties to the
Wagner company and even sued journalists
for reporting it in November Wagner
opened its official headquarters in St
Petersburg signaling that the once top
secret Fighters were going mainstream
Wagner Fighters first appeared publicly
in 2014 during Russia's Invasion and
annexation of Crimea since then they've
seemed to appear anywhere Russia has
interests they've operated in conflicts
around the world including in countries
in Africa and the Middle East and their
Fighters have historically been former
military or Special Forces private
military organizations are illegal in
Russia so most of Wagner's operations
have been kept in the shadows until
recently that is according to the UK
Ministry of Defense the Wagner group
started recruiting heavily last year
after Russia struggled to find recruits
for the regular army during its invasion
of Ukraine many of Wagner's recruits are
convicts pulled from prisons across
Russia pregosin himself has even been
filmed talking to prisoners in Ukraine
Wagner mercenaries are now estimated to
number some 50 000. a vast majority of
them convicts according to the
independent Russian human rights
organization Russia Behind Bars Wagner's
Reliance on prisoners as leading to high
rates of casualties and desertion
Ukrainian prosecutors have repeatedly
accused Wagner group mercenaries of war
crimes the U.S has designated the Wagner
group a transnational criminal
organization and both the EU and the US
have imposed sanctions on pergosin for
his role in the group there have also
been increasing tensions between the
Wagner group and the Russian military
pregosin has publicly called out the
Russian defense Ministry for its lack of
supplies and logistical support to
Wagner group Fighters according to the
institute for the study of War a
dc-based think tank pregosin could be
setting the conditions to blame failure
in bakmut on the Russian defense
Ministry